I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Pamsas. I'm wearing my Pamsas shirt. And I'm loving it. It is so stinking cute. I can't wait to get mine. They're really cute. And I, they're a conversation starter because I parked in the parking lot here at Airwolf. And as I was walking in, a guy, by the way, it was 10.50 a.m. The guy had a cocktail in his hand and said, what party are you going
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好，帕姆粉丝们。我穿着我的帕姆粉丝衬衫。我太喜欢它了。它真是可爱极了。我迫不及待想拿到我的那件。它们真的很可爱。而且，它们是开启对话的话题，因为我把车停在Airwolf的停车场。当我走进来时，一个家伙，顺便说一句，当时是上午10点50分。那家伙手里拿着鸡尾酒，问我，你要去参加什么派对？
to? I was like, he was in fluorescent yellow shorts with a white t-shirt. And I was like, I'm what? Is it because of my, is it because of my Pamsas shirt? You think I'm going to a party? I'm pretty sure it had absolutely nothing to do with your shirt that you could have been dressed in literally anything. This is 100% about him and his shorts and his cocktail before 11. Yeah. Well, he's, he's, he's doing it. All right. Today is Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 1. This is Season 4, Episode 3. This is another one of our one hour shows that was meant to kick off Season 4. We're dividing it into two parts. This episode was written by Michael Shore and it was directed by Craig
我当时想，他穿着荧光黄短裤和白色T恤。我心想，我什么？是因为我的，是因为我的帕姆粉丝衬衫吗？你以为我要去参加派对？我很确定这和你衬衫绝对没关系，你当时穿什么都一样。这百分之百是他和他那短裤，还有11点前的鸡尾酒的问题。是的。好吧，他，他，他正在做这件事。好了。今天是《邓德·米夫林无限》第一部分。这是第四季第三集。这是我们另一集一小时的节目，原本是为了开启第四季。我们把它分成两部分。这一集由迈克尔·舒尔编剧，克雷格·齐斯克执导。
Zisk. Yes. All right, Jenna, you're up. It's summery time. Here is a summary of what we are covering today. When Ryan tries to implement new ideas like issuing everyone a blackberry and announcing the new Dunder Mifflin Infinity website, Michael feels he may be a victim of ageism. Jim and Pam's relationship goes public and they are now forced to face the scrutiny of the entire staff. Meanwhile, Angela is going to give Dwight one more chance after his mercy killing of Sprinkles. Yep. All right. Fast fact number one, like I said, this episode was directed by Craig Zisk. He
是的。好了，珍娜，轮到你了。现在是总结时间。这是我们今天要涵盖的内容摘要。当瑞安试图实施新想法，比如给每个人发黑莓手机并宣布新的邓德·米夫林无限网站时，迈克尔觉得他可能成了年龄歧视的受害者。吉姆和帕姆的关系公开了，他们现在被迫面对全体员工的审视。与此同时，安吉拉在德怀特对斯普林克尔斯实施安乐死后，决定再给他一次机会。是的。好了。速记事实第一条，正如我所说，这一集由克雷格·齐斯克执导。他
had been an executive producer on Weeds, the United States of Terra, and the Larry Sanders show. And more recently, Brooklyn Nine-Nine, he's directed a ton of television. He directed a bunch of episodes of scrubs and movies. Do you remember Craig? I do remember Craig. And actually, when Craig came to direct, we had a little thing in common, which is I had worked with his brother, Randy Zisk, who's also a producer and director, and he had directed me on my episode of Monk. So when I saw Craig, we had, we sort of like had this moment. He was like, Hey, you were on my brother's show. And I was like, Yes, how are you?
曾担任《单身毒妈》、《美国塔拉》和《拉里·桑德斯秀》的执行制片人。最近还有《神烦警探》，他执导了大量的电视节目。他执导了许多集《实习医生风云》和电影。你还记得克雷格吗？我记得克雷格。事实上，当克雷格来执导时，我们有一个共同点，那就是我曾与他的兄弟兰迪·齐斯克合作过，他也是一位制片人和导演，他曾执导过我那一集的《神探阿蒙》。所以当我看到克雷格时，我们有一种，我们算是有了那种时刻。他说，嘿，你曾在我兄弟的节目里。我说，是的，你好吗？
Well, I had a little thing not in common with Craig, but in adoration of him. Because when he was 25 years old, he was one of the producers of the television show, Cop Rock. Do you remember Cop Rock, Angela? No, I've never heard of it. Oh my God. What? Oh my God. Okay. It came out in 1990. Okay. It was on ABC. It was Brace Yourself, a musical comedy drama
好吧，我和克雷格没什么共同点，但我很崇拜他。因为当他25岁时，他是电视节目《警察摇滚》的制片人之一。你还记得《警察摇滚》吗，安吉拉？不，我从没听说过。天哪。什么？天哪。好吧。它是在1990年播出的。好吧。它在ABC播出。它是一部，做好心理准备，音乐喜剧剧情
show about the LAPD. Oh my gosh, there's so much happening. Okay. It was created by Steven Bochko, who had also created the very famous Hill Street Blues. And basically, Angela, it was a cop show, like maybe imagine law and order. If all of a sudden, in the middle of the episode, they break into song. No. Yep. No, I can't, I can't do it.
关于洛杉矶警察局的节目。天哪，发生了太多事。好吧。它由史蒂文·博奇科创作，他也创作了非常著名的《希尔街的布鲁斯》。基本上，安吉拉，那是一部警察剧，就像想象一下《法律与秩序》。如果突然间，在剧集中间，他们开始唱歌。不。是的。不，我做不到，我做不到。
Here is an audio clip from an episode, you know, when they all gather in the room and like the lieutenant is like, here's what's on the docket today. We got this happening and this happening. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That's what he's doing at the top of this scene. Sam, will you play the clip? Sam, last on the teletype, we still got the Franklin Avenue flashers. Okay. That's it. And hey, hey, let's be careful out there. Let's be careful out there.
这是一段来自剧集的音频片段，你知道，当他们都聚集在房间里，中尉说，这是今天的日程安排。我们有这个和那个要处理。是的。是的。好吧。这就是他在场景开头所做的。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？萨姆，电传打字机上的最后一条消息，我们还有富兰克林大道的暴露狂。好吧。就是这样。嘿，嘿，在那儿要小心。在那儿要小心。
No, they did not. They did. No, they didn't. It was canceled after 11 episodes. Why? TV Guide ranked it number eight on its list of the 50 worst TV shows of all time in 2002. Wow. But it actually won two Emmy Awards for editing and outstanding achievement in music and lyrics.
不，他们没这么做。他们做了。不，他们没做。它在11集后被取消了。为什么？《电视指南》在2002年将其列为史上50部最差电视节目榜单的第八名。哇。但它实际上获得了两项艾美奖，分别是剪辑和音乐与歌词杰出成就奖。
I want you to know I loved this show. I watched every episode. This is all we need to know about you, Jenna. It was like glee, but a cop show. It was brilliant. You can find it on YouTube. It sounds like an SNL parody of like a cop show or something. That is amazing. I now have to go see just one. I mean, I mean, I have to see one where they're like, we got the perp in the cell. We're going to frisk him now. I think that's a song. I think there's I got the perp. Frisk him up. Oh, frisk him up, frisk him up, frisk him up, frisk him up, frisk him down. What did
我想让你知道我喜欢这个节目。我看了每一集。这就是我们需要了解的关于你的一切，珍娜。它就像《欢乐合唱团》，但是一部警察剧。它太棒了。你可以在YouTube上找到它。听起来像是《周六夜现场》对警察剧的恶搞之类的。那太神奇了。我现在必须去看一集。我是说，我必须看一集他们说，我们抓住了牢房里的罪犯。我们现在要搜他的身。我想那是一首歌。我想有我抓住了罪犯。搜他的身。哦，搜他的身，搜他的身，搜他的身，搜他的身，搜他的身。你发现了什么？
you find? Is there a gun? Is there a knife? Are you just happy to see me? The show really rates itself. Oh my gosh. Wow. I want you to be safe out there. You heard him. Be safe. Be safe. This is no like a hybrid West Side Story cop rock. That's all I could picture in my mind. Oh my Lord. Okay. That's amazing. And Craig worked on it. He was one of the producers. Well, I'll bring us back with fast fact number two. Okay. This episode, Dunder Mifflin Infinity aired in October of 2007. And also in October 2007 was a big office convention in Scranton, Pennsylvania. Yes. And a whole bunch of us went. A huge group. I mean, it was like Greg went and Mike
有枪吗？有刀吗？你只是很高兴见到我吗？这个节目真的很有趣。天哪。哇。我希望你在外面注意安全。你听到他说的了。注意安全。注意安全。这不像是一部混合了《西区故事》和《警察摇滚》的作品。我脑子里只能想到这个。天哪。好吧。那太神奇了。克雷格参与了制作。他是制片人之一。好吧，我带回速记事实第二条。好吧。这一集，《邓德·米夫林无限》于2007年10月播出。2007年10月也是宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿举行大型《办公室》大会的时候。是的。我们很多人都去了。一个庞大的团队。我是说，格雷格去了，迈克
Schur and Jen Salata, a bunch of the writers and the cast. I think the whole entire cast was there except for you and Steve, right? And John, everyone else went like the whole shebang. I was not allowed to go because remember I shared last week about how I broke my back. Yeah. I was not cleared for plane travel at this time. I was super sad you weren't there. I found some emails where we traded emails. You're like, please tell everyone I said hi. But it was a absolute blast. Scranton was so much fun. Scranton. Everyone there was great. And then me and Craig and Brian went on the Today Show with Al Roker. Al Roker came to Scranton and we did the Today Show
舒尔和詹·萨拉塔，还有很多编剧和演员。我想除了你和史蒂夫，整个剧组都在那儿，对吧？还有约翰，其他人都去了，就像整个团队。我不被允许去，因为记得我上周分享过我怎么摔断了背吗？是的。我当时没被批准乘飞机旅行。你没去我超级难过。我发现了一些我们交换的电子邮件。你说，请告诉大家我向他们问好。但那绝对是一次狂欢。斯克兰顿太有趣了。斯克兰顿。那里的每个人都很棒。然后我和克雷格还有布莱恩上了阿尔·罗克的《今日秀》。阿尔·罗克来到斯克兰顿，我们和他一起在那里做了《今日秀》。
from there with him. And I mean, it was just a blast. I was so jealous. That looked like so much fun. You guys did like a whole Q&A panel and like a meet and greet, right? And we did like a concert. Like there was a concert and a bunch of people from the office performed like Craig and Melora and like everyone got up on stage. It was so much fun. But you know, lady, this was something you and I both share because I was able to go to this convention. But then at the end of the show, there was another one like a big rap party convention and it was my daughter's birthday. So you went to that one. So I found all these emails, Jenna, where we sort of
我的意思是，那真是太棒了。我太嫉妒了。看起来太有趣了。你们做了一个完整的问答小组和见面会，对吧？我们还办了一场音乐会。就像有一场音乐会，很多《办公室》的人都表演了，比如克雷格和梅洛拉，每个人都上了台。太有趣了。但你知道，女士，这是你我共同经历的事情，因为我能去参加这次大会。但在节目结束时，还有另一场，像是一个大型的杀青派对大会，那是我女儿的生日。所以你去了那一场。所以我发现了所有这些邮件，珍娜，我们算是
bookend this experience for each other because I went to one and you got to go to the other. Yeah. I remember that. I was so glad I got to go to that one at the end of the show because I couldn't, I couldn't like leave the experience of the office having never visited Scranton. So I just remember I was really jealous that you got to go and I was bummed that I had to stay home. But you know, well, you know, we've never gotten to go together and that's on my bucket list. When this podcast is done, I want you and I to go to Scranton. That's on my wish list. I want you and I to go to Scranton and just anonymously sign up for the office tour and just show up and be like, take us on the tour.
为彼此书写了这段经历的结尾，因为我去了其中一个，你去了另一个。是的。我记得。我很高兴我能去最后那一个，因为我不能，我不能在没去过斯克兰顿的情况下就离开《办公室》的经历。所以我只记得我很嫉妒你能去，而我很沮丧我必须待在家里。但你知道，好吧，你知道，我们从来没能一起去过，那在我的遗愿清单上。当这个播客结束时，我希望你和我去斯克兰顿。那在我的愿望清单上。我希望你和我去斯克兰顿，然后匿名报名参加《办公室》之旅，直接出现，然后说，带我们去参观吧。
Yes, to all the spots. I want to do it. Well, listen, there was something else going on during this time. I don't know if you remember, but we were on the cover of Entertainment Weekly Magazine. We were? It came out October 5th, which was the day after this episode aired. And there were a few sets of couples. Steve and Melora as Jan and Michael were on one cover and then Angela and Dwight were on one and Jim and Pam and then Ryan and Kelly. So you could pick which issue had the cover, but then we were all on the inside in this big group photo. I remember doing that photo shoot. It was so fun. It was such a such a cool day and I couldn't believe it. Like I had always, you know, picked up Entertainment
是的，去所有的地方。我想做这件事。好吧，听着，当时还有别的事情发生。我不知道你记不记得，但我们上了《娱乐周刊》杂志的封面。我们上了吗？它在10月5日出版，也就是这一集播出后的第二天。有几对情侣。史蒂夫和梅洛拉作为简和迈克尔上了一个封面，然后安吉拉和德怀特上了一个，吉姆和帕姆，还有瑞安和凯利。所以你可以选择哪一期有封面，但我们都在内页的一张大合影里。我记得拍那张照片。太有趣了。那是如此酷的一天，我简直不敢相信。就像我一直，你知道，拿起《娱乐周刊》。
Weekly. I love television. It was like my dream to be on TV and then to all of a sudden be on the cover and be in it with you guys. I couldn't even believe it. I have one framed. Well, this is what was happening at this time, which was that the show was truly blowing up and we were on covers of magazines and it was so surreal. Early on, I tried to save every single mention of us or the show from any publication because I it just felt so fleeting. And then at this time, it became it became impossible. It was just constant and we were really out in the zeitgeist. Is that the right word? Yeah, yeah, no, the show was just really catching on. I'll tell you what, between my mom and my grandmother
我热爱电视。能上电视是我的梦想，然后突然上了封面，还和你们在一起。我简直不敢相信。我装裱了一张。好吧，这就是当时发生的事情，节目真的火了，我们上了杂志封面，这太超现实了。早期，我试图保存任何出版物中提到我们或节目的每一条信息，因为我觉得它太短暂了。然后在这个时候，它变得，它变得不可能了。这简直是持续不断的，我们真的处于时代精神之中。那是正确的词吗？是的，是的，不，节目真的开始流行了。我告诉你，在我妈妈和我祖母
and my cousin Carol and my Aunt Brenda, I think I have everything we were ever mentioned in because they saved everything and they would send it to me. Well, speaking of being out in the world in a big way, Fast Fact number three, we got a lot of fan mail from people about the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website and they wanted to know if it was real. Well, it was real and it went out into the world around this exact same time as this episode. That is right. And we reached out to Joya Balfour. Joya, as you remember, Jenna was part of the team at NBC.com. And you guys, networks were not doing digital content during this time. It's just something they didn't do. So NBC was really on the forefront and
还有我的表姐卡罗尔和我阿姨布伦达之间，我想我拥有所有提到过我们的东西，因为她们保存了一切，还会寄给我。好吧，说到在世界上产生巨大影响，速记事实第三条，我们收到了很多粉丝关于邓德·米夫林无限网站的来信，他们想知道它是否真实。好吧，它是真实的，它大约在这一集播出的同一时间发布到世界上。没错。我们联系了乔亚·巴尔福。乔亚，正如你记得的，珍娜，她是NBC.com团队的一员。你们知道，当时电视网并没有在做数字内容。这是他们根本不做的事情。所以NBC真的走在了前沿，
I talked to Joya and she was saying they were trying to find ways to sustain the fandom to keep fans engaged. And one of the things they did was they launched Dunder Mifflin Infinity.com. You could go on and play these games. There were virtual branches that fans could join. They could perform tasks where they would earn shrewt bucks. And then they could spend their shrewt bucks on virtual items in sort of like the office. And they went around to all of our desks. They took pictures of the set so that they could actually buy virtual items. And this site ran for three years on NBC.com. And fans got signed items from the show. And also if they submitted their artwork, it would be displayed in episodes.
我和乔亚谈过，她说他们正在努力寻找维持粉丝群的方法，让粉丝保持参与。他们做的事情之一就是推出了DunderMifflinInfinity.com。你可以去玩这些游戏。有粉丝可以加入的虚拟分部。他们可以执行任务，赚取施鲁特币。然后他们可以用施鲁特币在《办公室》里购买虚拟物品。他们去了我们所有的办公桌。他们拍了布景的照片，这样他们就可以真正购买虚拟物品。这个网站在NBC.com上运行了三年。粉丝们得到了节目中签名的物品。而且如果他们提交了艺术作品，它还会显示在剧集中。
Jenna, fan art was put around the set. So your art might make it into the show. It might end up on the refrigerator in the kitchen or on a bulletin board like by Creed and Meredith. And fans could look for their art if they won. Isn't that amazing? It's really incredible because I just want to remind everyone, there was no Instagram. There were no apps back then. Like this was really, really revolutionary in terms of that idea of fan engagement and getting to participate in some way actively with your favorite show. Yes. And they even made a video. And actually, I have audio of it. Sam, can you play the video of DunderMifflinInfinity.com?
珍娜，粉丝艺术被放在布景周围。所以你的艺术作品可能会出现在节目中。它可能会出现在厨房的冰箱上，或者像克里德和梅雷迪思旁边的公告栏上。如果粉丝赢了，他们可以寻找他们的艺术作品。那不是很神奇吗？这真的很不可思议，因为我只是想提醒大家，当时没有Instagram。那时没有应用程序。就像在粉丝参与和以某种方式积极参与你最喜欢的节目方面，这真的，真的具有革命性。是的。他们甚至制作了一个视频。事实上，我有它的音频。萨姆，你能播放DunderMifflinInfinity.com的视频吗？
Do you like paper? Well, we like you. DunderMifflin is looking for bright, energetic paper people to open up their own branch and become part of the DunderMifflin family. Interested in your own future? Go to DunderMifflinInfinity.com to find out more. I love it. Isn't that great? And I asked Joia, who did that voiceover? And she said, that's just a voiceover actor that they hired. She has a whole page on her website, JoiaBalfor.com, where you can look at DunderMifflin Infinity and what all they did with it. You can actually watch that video that we just played for you. And I told Joia over the next few episodes and next few seasons, I'm going to reach out to her, kind of like your kentipedia, because
你喜欢纸吗？好吧，我们喜欢你。邓德·米夫林正在寻找聪明、精力充沛的纸业人才来开设他们自己的分部，并成为邓德·米夫林大家庭的一员。对你自己的未来感兴趣吗？去DunderMifflinInfinity.com了解更多。我喜欢它。那不是很棒吗？我问乔亚，是谁做的配音？她说，那只是他们雇佣的一位配音演员。她在她的网站JoyaBalfor.com上有一个完整的页面，你可以在那里查看邓德·米夫林无限以及他们用它做了什么。你实际上可以观看我们刚才为你播放的那个视频。我告诉乔亚，在接下来的几集和接下来的几季里，我会联系她，有点像你的肯蒂百科，因为
I really started becoming a more active participant on NBC.com. I did a thing called Adventures with Angela. We had the accountants' webisodes. There were a lot more fun things we started to do. And I'm going to hit her up along the way. I love that. They should relaunch this. They should relaunch DunderMifflin Infinity as an app. I know. And you can do all these same things. Someone, Joia, I don't know, who does this? Peacock, get on it. Peacock, are you listening? Do this. Yeah. Well, lady, listen, I think we should take a break. Those were incredible fast facts. We are killing it today and giving us compliments. But let's take a break and then we'll come back in and get
我真的开始成为NBC.com上更积极的参与者。我做了一个叫《安吉拉历险记》的东西。我们有会计师的网络剧。我们开始做更多有趣的事情。我会在过程中联系她。我喜欢那个。他们应该重新推出这个。他们应该把邓德·米夫林无限作为应用程序重新推出。我知道。你可以做所有这些同样的事情。有人，乔亚，我不知道，谁做这个？孔雀台，行动起来。孔雀台，你在听吗？做这件事。是的。好吧，女士，听着，我想我们应该休息一下。那些是令人难以置信的速记事实。我们今天表现得太棒了，还给了我们赞美。但让我们休息一下，然后回来
into this episode. Okay, great, because I've got more details, lady. More details. I know I'm not kentipedia, but maybe I'm kensipedia on this one. Kensipedia after the break. Kensipedia. All right, we are back. And we open this episode in the break room where there is no more heart break. In fact, there is flirty flirt cuteness in there. In fact, I'm pretty sure it's now called the flirt room. I think you're right. Jim and Pam. Pam has already gotten Jim a soda. Because she knows what he likes because she's his girlfriend. And then she gives him a little peck, little kiss as she's leaving. But Toby sees. Can we talk about Paul's expression? We can. I froze on his face. I was laughing so hard. I don't even know what all it's
进入这一集。好吧，太棒了，因为我有更多细节，女士。更多细节。我知道我不是肯蒂百科，但也许我是这个方面的肯斯百科。休息后的肯斯百科。肯斯百科。好吧，我们回来了。我们在这集的休息室里开场，那里不再有心碎。事实上，里面有调情般的可爱。事实上，我很确定它现在被称为调情室。我想你是对的。吉姆和帕姆。帕姆已经给吉姆拿了苏打水。因为她知道他喜欢什么，因为她是他的女朋友。然后她在离开时给了他一个小吻。但托比看到了。我们能谈谈保罗的表情吗？我们可以。我定格在他的脸上。我笑得太厉害了。我甚至不知道这一切在
conveying. It's conveying so many things at 20 seconds, Toby's face. Well, Paul does some amazing reaction acting in this episode. If you are an actor and you would like to study great reactions, this is a real good one to study. Yeah. Well, what happens after this is that Toby puts out a memo regarding PDA in the workplace and everyone's reading it. And Jim and Pam are like, what is this about? Toby is so passive aggressive. He really is. He clearly has issue, but he's going to put out a memo. Come on, Toby. Well, Michael thinks that the memo is about that night that he and Jan did some stuff in his office. But I mean, he says almost everyone was gone for the day. This is ridiculous, Toby. Yeah.
传达什么，20秒时托比的脸。好吧，保罗在这一集中做了一些惊人的反应表演。如果你是一名演员，并且你想学习伟大的反应，这是一个非常好的学习案例。是的。好吧，在这之后发生的是，托比发布了一份关于工作场所公开示爱的备忘录，每个人都在读它。吉姆和帕姆都在想，这是关于什么的？托比真是太被动攻击了。他确实是。他显然有问题，但他要发布一份备忘录。得了吧，托比。好吧，迈克尔认为这份备忘录是关于那天晚上他和简在他的办公室里做了一些事情。但我的意思是，他说几乎每个人都下班了。这太荒谬了，托比。是的。
And then Angela thinks it might be about her and Dwight. So she yells from across the room and makes this big statement that she's never been intimate with anyone in the office. And that is when Toby says, no, no, it was a complaint about Jim and Pam. And then he basically outs their relationship to the whole office. I mean, Toby, this is twice now because he did this with Oscar. And now with Jim and Pam, he's announced that they're dating and everyone freaks out, but no one, no one freaks out more than Michael. Well, Michael is giddy. Michael doesn't even know what to do with himself. And Steve's performance is so sweet. He is so genuinely excited that Jim and Pam are together. He makes them hold hands and
然后安吉拉认为这可能是关于她和德怀特的。所以她从房间对面大喊，并发表了一个大声明，说她从未与办公室里的任何人亲密过。就在那时，托比说，不，不，这是关于吉姆和帕姆的投诉。然后他基本上向整个办公室揭露了他们的关系。我的意思是，托比，这已经是第二次了，因为他之前对奥斯卡也这么做过。现在对吉姆和帕姆，他宣布他们在约会，每个人都吓坏了，但没有人，没有人比迈克尔更抓狂。好吧，迈克尔是头晕目眩的。迈克尔甚至不知道该拿自己怎么办。史蒂夫的表演太甜了。他真的为吉姆和帕姆在一起感到兴奋。他让他们牵手，
he makes a big declaration. This day will go down in infamy. He makes you guys hold hands and then he really bear hugs Jim. And then he goes to hug you, but your phone starts ringing and Pam's like, oh, like rescued by my phone. And he's like, no, no, Pam, let it ring. Let the bells of Dunder Mifflin chime out your love. But then he has that really famous line that I've seen people write on their graduation hats. I've seen it everywhere. I've seen it like stitched on a pillow on a graduation hat. It's, it's so good. Say it, Ange. My heart soars with the eagle's nest. Incredible. Now we said this episode was written by Mike Schur and that has to be a Mike Schur special right there. It has
他发表了一个大声明。这一天将作为耻辱日载入史册。他让你们牵手，然后他真的给了吉姆一个熊抱。然后他去拥抱你，但你的电话开始响了，帕姆就像，哦，就像被我的电话救了一样。他说，不，不，帕姆，让它响吧。让邓德·米夫林的钟声敲响你们的爱情。但随后他说了那句非常有名的台词，我见过人们把它写在毕业帽上。我到处都见过。我见过它像缝在枕头上，在毕业帽上。它，它太棒了。说出来，安吉。我的心随着鹰巢翱翔。不可思议。现在我们说这一集是由迈克·舒尔写的，那一定是迈克·舒尔的特别之处。它必须
to be. Now we see a series of talking heads. And Jenna, I was very curious about this because you like to deep dive on positioning. Ooh, that sounds like a, that's what she said. That sounded different than what I think you mean. Go on. As it was coming out of my mouth, I knew it was wrong. Oh, that's what she said. That's what she said. So Dwight's talking head. He's like, I don't see it. I think they could do better. He is sitting in front of the wall and off of his left shoulder is the bullpen. Right? Yep. Yep. Then it cuts to me. And I say, I'm not surprised. Pam is the office mattress, which is such a great line. But I'm sitting in front of the window with the
是。现在我们看到了一系列谈话头。珍娜，我对此非常好奇，因为你喜欢深入研究定位。哦，那听起来像是一个，那是她说的。那听起来和我认为你的意思不一样。继续。当它从我嘴里说出来时，我就知道它错了。哦，那是她说的。那是她说的。所以德怀特的谈话头。他说，我不明白。我认为他们可以做得更好。他坐在墙前，他的左肩外是办公区。对吧？是的。是的。然后切到我。我说，我不惊讶。帕姆是办公室的床垫，这真是一句很棒的台词。但我坐在窗前，
wall to my right shoulder. Yeah, there's more wall and more window depending on who's talking head it is. It's not always the exact same shot. I noticed that too. And then it cuts to Andy and he's framed the exact same way that Dwight was. And I'm, I realize I'm becoming one of the fans of the show where I'm like, hmm, is there something there? But I'm like, this is an interesting love triangle that's about to play out. And this is a little bit of a Dwight Angela Andy sandwich. I don't think you are reading into it. I noticed the same thing. I feel like they purposely didn't set all the shots the same. And they also differentiated Angela from the two men. Yeah, that can't be an accident. It can't be. All right, well,
墙在我的右肩。是的，根据是谁的谈话头，有更多的墙和更多的窗户。它并不总是完全相同的镜头。我也注意到了。然后切到安迪，他的构图和德怀特完全一样。我意识到我正在成为节目的粉丝之一，我想，嗯，那里有什么东西吗？但我心想，这是一个即将上演的有趣的三角恋。这是一个小小的德怀特、安吉拉、安迪三明治。我不认为你在过度解读。我也注意到了同样的事情。我觉得他们故意没有把所有的镜头设置得一样。而且他们还把安吉拉和那两个男人区分开了。是的，那不可能是意外。不可能是。好吧，好吧，
now we're going to get into the episode, right? We have our opening credits. And the first scene is the party planning committee. They're setting up for Ryan's return. Phyllis and Angela are hanging a banner that says welcome back, Ryan. Three minutes, 28 seconds, skin alert. What's a skin alert? Well, my sweater in this episode, I feel like the dry clean shrunk it like it fit one day and then the next got a little tighter. And as I'm hanging the banner, you see like my mid rift. Oh my gosh, that's very out of character for Angela Martin. It's very scandalous. It's scandalous. Well, double skin alert. Kelly arrives. She is all jujda. She's like, Oh, is Ryan coming back today? I had no idea. She looks super cutie pie.
现在我们要进入这一集了，对吧？我们有片头字幕。第一个场景是派对策划委员会。他们正在为瑞安的回归做准备。菲利斯和安吉拉挂着一条写着欢迎回来，瑞安的横幅。3分钟28秒，皮肤警报。什么是皮肤警报？好吧，我在这一集的毛衣，我觉得干洗把它缩水了，它有一天很合身，然后第二天变得有点紧。当我挂横幅时，你看到了我的中段。天哪，这对安吉拉·马丁来说太不符合性格了。这太丑闻了。这太丑闻了。好吧，双重皮肤警报。凯利到了。她全副武装。她说，哦，瑞安今天回来吗？我一点都不知道。她看起来超级可爱。
She looks super cutie pie. We also in this scene have a list of that's what she says that Michael had ready to go. Oh, please, please read it. Here it is. Can you make that straighter? That job looks hard. You should put your mouth on that. You might want to trim it a little. Yeah. I liked it when he said you might want to put your mouth on that and Pam says how I don't understand how you were even planning to use that naturally. And he was like under his breath. He's like, if you if you were blowing up balloons, I was just balloons. I had it ready. I was ready to go. Well, now we have sort of a interesting little spy shot. We've got some black and white footage of the elevator bay, which is
她看起来超级可爱。在这个场景中，我们还有迈克尔准备好的那是她说的列表。哦，请，请读一下。在这里。你能把它弄直一点吗？那项工作看起来很难。你应该把你的嘴放在上面。你可能想稍微修剪一下。是的，我喜欢他说你可能想把你的嘴放在上面，帕姆说怎么我不明白你甚至打算怎么自然地使用它。他就在他呼吸下。他说，如果你，如果你在吹气球，我只是气球。我准备好了。我准备好了。好吧，现在我们有了一个有趣的间谍镜头。我们有一些电梯间的黑白镜头，这是
meant to be, I guess, security camera footage. Yeah, but they this is like something we don't do on the show. So it was jarring to me when I saw it again, because I hadn't seen this episode in so long. And I was like, whoa, what's up with the security camera footage? Well, what was odd is that we then switch to a spy shot from our regular documentary camera. Yeah. So it was a little bit I found it a little bit odd as well. But that's what that black and white footage is supposed to be. And the reason they're showing this is because Dwight and Angela have met in this elevator vestibule so that he can present her with a new cat, a feral barn cat, feral, feral. How do you say feral, feral, feral
意味着是，我想是安全摄像头镜头。是的，但他们，这是我们在节目中不做的事情。所以当我再次看到它时，它让我感到刺耳，因为我很久没看这一集了。我当时想，哇，安全摄像头镜头是怎么回事？好吧，奇怪的是，我们随后切换到了我们常规纪录片摄像机的间谍镜头。是的。所以我发现它也有一点奇怪。但这就是那些黑白镜头应该有的样子。他们展示这个的原因是因为德怀特和安吉拉在这个电梯前厅见面，这样他就可以送给她一只新猫，一只野生的谷仓猫，野生的，野生的。你怎么说野生的，野生的，野生的
you say tomato, you say feral, feral, a feral cat, a feral cat, feral, feral. It's feral, right? It's tomato tomato, Sam. Feral. Oh, Sam sided with me. And Dwight says feral in the episode. But anyway, Jenna, we'll just we'll just chunk that aside and let you say feral. Listeners, do any of you say feral, please write us. Alright, so yes, Dwight gives her garbage. And this poor cat, they put like stuff in its hair to make it look kind of grungy like it had been eating garbage. Well, we had a fan question from Rivka Wasserman. Did they gel the cat's hair before the shoot to make him look like more of a stray cat? Well, I reached out to Kim Ferry and she said they did that her memory is that the trainer had a little bit of honey.
你说番茄，你说野生的，野生的，一只野猫，一只野猫，野生的，野生的。是野生的，对吧？是番茄番茄，萨姆。野生的。哦，萨姆站在我这边。德怀特在这一集中说了野生的。但无论如何，珍娜，我们只是，我们只是把那个放在一边，让你说野生的。听众们，你们有人说野生的吗，请写信给我们。好吧，所以是的，德怀特给了她垃圾。这只可怜的猫，他们在它的毛里放了东西，让它看起来有点脏，就像它一直在吃垃圾一样。好吧，我们有一个来自里夫卡·瓦瑟曼的粉丝问题。他们在拍摄前给猫的毛涂了发胶，让它看起来更像流浪猫吗？好吧，我联系了金·费里，她说他们确实那样做了，她的记忆是训练师有一点蜂蜜。
We had warned the trainer of this very well trained domesticated cat that we wanted it to look feral. And so they suggested something natural like honey to kind of rough up the cat's fur. And so that's what they used. Yes, these trainers were so great with the cats and obviously honey isn't going to do anything, you know, that's just like organic. I do have amazing memories of this scene. I want you guys to know that this cat was crawling all over rain, all over him. Well, you can see it in the episode like every shot the cat is in a different position. It kept jumping out of his arms. And so we really had to sort of deliver the emotion of the scene but get our lines out quickly because this thing was climbing off rain and wanted to go exploring the whole
我们警告过这只训练有素的家猫的训练师，我们想让它看起来野性。所以他们建议用蜂蜜之类的天然东西来弄乱猫的毛。所以这就是他们用的。是的，这些训练师对猫太棒了，显然蜂蜜不会做任何事情，你知道，那只是有机的。我确实对这个场景有惊人的记忆。我想让你们知道，这只猫在雷恩身上爬来爬去。好吧，你可以在这一集中看到，每一帧猫的位置都不一样。它一直从他怀里跳出来。所以我们真的必须传达场景的情绪，但要快速说出我们的台词，因为这东西正从雷恩身上爬下来，想去探索整个
scene. Well, my favorite is the shot where it's like clearly crawling over his shoulder and then one second later he's holding it like a baby. Yeah. In his arms because amazing. Clearly the cat was everywhere. The cat was everywhere and the cat wranglers were like stepping in and being like, okay, here, try holding him this way. Try this. When the cat jumps out of rain's arms at the end, that was like the easiest moment to film because it wanted to go explore. Well, Ange, a lot of people asked if this was the same cat that Andy gives you later that becomes Bandit. I mean, it's, I wouldn't think it was meant to be the same cat. Like I think what they're thinking is, oh Dwight lets this cat go and then years later Andy finds it again and calls it Bandit. Well,
场景。好吧，我最喜欢的是它明显爬过他肩膀的镜头，然后一秒钟后他像抱婴儿一样抱着它。是的。在他怀里，因为太神奇了。显然猫到处都是。猫到处都是，猫的驯兽师走进来，说，好吧，在这里，试着这样抱着它。试着这样。当猫在最后从雷恩怀里跳出来时，那是最容易拍摄的时刻，因为它想去探索。好吧，安吉，很多人问这是否是安迪后来给你的那只变成班迪特的猫。我的意思是，我，我不认为它被认为是同一只猫。就像我想他们想的是，哦，德怀特放走了这只猫，然后几年后安迪又发现了它，叫它班迪特。好吧，
that would be hilarious, but that was never conveyed to us in the script. It's just that Andy wants to give Angela a cat. What I found interesting about that, and obviously we're gonna get to that episode is that Angela accepts the cat from Andy, right? Yeah. But does not accept the cat from Dwight and does it right in front of Dwight to sort of, you know, just really drive the point home that he's not, he's not her fella anymore. Well, as a person who worked in Animal Rescue for years and years, I will tell you that I don't recommend giving pets as gifts because so many of the pets that are surrendered were gifts that people were not prepared to take care of in the long run, or they break up or whatever happens. I just think people should pick their own pets,
那会很搞笑，但剧本里从来没传达给我们。只是安迪想给安吉拉一只猫。我发现有趣的是，显然我们要讲到那一集，安吉拉接受了安迪的猫，对吧？是的。但没有接受德怀特的猫，而且就在德怀特面前做，为了，你知道，真正把重点带回家，他不是，他不再是她的男朋友了。好吧，作为一个在动物救援中心工作了多年的人，我会告诉你，我不建议把宠物作为礼物，因为很多被遗弃的宠物都是人们没有准备好长期照顾的礼物，或者他们分手了，或者发生了什么事。我只是认为人们应该选择自己的宠物，
or really what my mom always said is let the pet pick you. That's how you get your match. Yeah. I like that. I definitely feel our pets picked us for sure. Yeah, that's how we got sunny. We went into this rescue center because we were told that one of the volunteers was gonna bring in this box of fluffy gray and white cats. They were so cute. They'd sent us pictures. My daughter was all excited. And we got there and the woman was running late. So they took us into a room with all of these adoptable cats and kittens and this one little scrappy orange fella would not leave us alone. I always say it was like he walked up to us and he was like, Hey guys, what's up? Good to see you. My name is Sunny. I'll be coming home with you. You can take a look at these other guys
或者我妈妈总是说，让宠物选择你。这就是你得到匹配的方式。是的。我喜欢那个。我绝对觉得我们的宠物选择了我们。是的，这就是我们得到桑尼的方式。我们走进这个救援中心，因为有人告诉我们，其中一名志愿者会带进来一箱毛茸茸的灰白猫。它们太可爱了。他们给我们发了照片。我女儿很兴奋。我们到了那里，那个女人迟到了。所以他们带我们进了一个房间，里面有所有这些可供领养的猫和幼猫，这只 scrappy 的橙色小家伙不肯离开我们。我总是说，就像他走到我们面前，说，嘿，伙计们，怎么了？很高兴见到你。我叫桑尼。我会和你一起回家。你可以看看这些其他人
if you want, but I will be your cat. Yeah. And that's kind of how we got sunny. He wouldn't leave us alone. Yeah. We could never have been happier. That was biscuit. Biscuit just tried to hide in my sweatshirt and I thought, well, you got to come home with me now. Exactly. My sweatshirt is your home. Well, listen, switching gears back to the show. Yeah, don't get us started on our rescue pets. It'd be a huge tangent. Pam and Jim are gonna go out to Toby and offer to sign one of the famous love documents. Yes, the relationship disclosure form. And Toby's like, you know what? That's only for people who are serious. And he's sort of implying this isn't serious, right? Because you know, Toby has his big crush on Pam. And so he's hoping this is casual. But Jenna,
如果你想的话，但我会成为你的猫。是的。这就是我们得到桑尼的方式。他不肯离开我们。是的。我们再也不会更快乐了。那是饼干。饼干刚才试图躲在我的运动衫里，我想，好吧，你现在得跟我回家了。完全正确。我的运动衫就是你的家。好吧，听着，切换回节目。是的，别让我们开始谈论我们的救援宠物。那会是一个巨大的离题。帕姆和吉姆要去找托比，提出签署一份著名的爱情文件。是的，关系披露表。托比说，你知道吗？那只适用于认真的人。他有点暗示这不认真，对吧？因为你知道，托比对帕姆有很大的迷恋。所以他希望这是随意的。但珍娜，
there's a great scene in the bloopers where at the end of the scene, Toby just tries to hold Pam's hand in front of Jim. And you guys couldn't get through it. You just start laughing. I remember trying to shoot that. I don't think we ever got it. And that's why we never included it. But it was also just something we thought was so funny in the moment. It was like an improvisation that Toby would slowly try to hold Pam's hand during the scene and squeeze her hand. Yeah. And Jim's like, what's happening? Well, then Ryan returns. Yes, Ryan with his new look and his love of Black Berries walks in. Oh my God. BJ's performance is so good when he's absorbed in his phone. And Pam's like, Hey, Ryan, well, he's like one second. And then like, after he's done typing, he puts it down.
在花絮中有一个很棒的场景，在场景结束时，托比只是试图在吉姆面前握住帕姆的手。你们无法完成它。你们只是开始笑。我记得试图拍摄那个。我不认为我们拍到了。这就是为什么我们从未包括它。但这只是我们当时认为非常有趣的事情。这就像一个即兴表演，托比会在场景中慢慢试图握住帕姆的手，挤压她的手。是的。吉姆说，发生了什么？好吧，然后瑞安回来了。是的，瑞安带着他的新造型和对黑莓手机的热爱走了进来。天哪。BJ的表演太棒了，当他沉浸在手机里时。帕姆说，嘿，瑞安，他就像等一下。然后就像，在他打完字后，他把它放下了。
And he's like, Hey, Pam, how's it going? It was so good. Well, you know, in this scene, I know what you guys are all really here to find out about is a sad plant alert. Oh, no. Six minutes, seven seconds, sad plant. I think Pam now for sure the plants aren't going to have a chance because she's in love. Yeah, she doesn't have time for that. It's the tiniest little like two like green leaves sticking out of the pot. It's like so tiny. Well, the thing that I remember about this scene, Angela, is when the character of Kevin runs up to Ryan and like ruffles his hair. He gives him a noogie. He like puts him in a headlock and gives him a noogie. Those guys could not get through that moment. Every time it would make BJ laugh, BJ thought it was so funny. And he would break. And I
他说，嘿，帕姆，怎么样？太棒了。好吧，你知道，在这个场景中，我知道你们所有人真正来这里是为了找出关于悲伤植物警报的信息。哦，不。6分钟7秒，悲伤植物。我想帕姆现在肯定植物没机会了，因为她恋爱了。是的，她没时间做那个。它就像盆里伸出来的最微小的两片绿叶。它太小了。好吧，我记得关于这个场景的事情，安吉拉，是当凯文这个角色跑到瑞安身边，弄乱他的头发时。他给了他一个 noogie。他像把他锁喉，给了他一个 noogie。那些家伙无法完成那个时刻。每次都会让BJ笑，BJ觉得这太有趣了。他会笑场。我
remember we couldn't get through it. And Brian too. I loved it when when he's like fire guy. And then Andy comes over and he's like fire guy. And Brian is Kevin is like, you weren't here for that. And then Andy says here for what? Yeah. So good. It's so good. Well, we had a fan question from Lauren C. She wanted to know about Ryan's new look. You know, he's got the facial stubble. He's slicked his hair back. He's wearing a fancy suit. Lauren wants to know was BJ told to grow facial hair for this season where he's the boss? Or did he just personally decide to grow some? Well, I texted BJ about this. He said this look was definitely not a personal choice. He said he thinks it was a pitch by Jean and Lee. At first the pitch was a goatee. But Greg
记得我们无法完成它。布莱恩也是。我喜欢当他说火人时。然后安迪走过来，他说火人。布莱恩是凯文，他说你没在这里经历过那个。然后安迪说在这里经历什么？是的。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我们有一个来自劳伦C的粉丝问题。她想知道瑞安的新造型。你知道，他有面部胡茬。他把头发向后梳。他穿着一件时髦的西装。劳伦想知道BJ是否被告知要为这一季他当老板时留胡子？还是他只是个人决定留一些？好吧，我给BJ发了短信。他说这个造型绝对不是个人选择。他说他认为这是吉恩和李的提议。起初提议是山羊胡。但格雷格
said no. He said it was two on the nose. Yeah, go to is too much. The whole look was very kind of like Gordon Gekko, you know, the movie Wall Street. It was like, you know, Ryan thinks he's the king of New York now. Yes. BJ said that he always just kind of rolled with pitches like this. And then he said case in point, the upcoming blonde hair. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Ryan's going to go through a few looks before this whole thing is over. Well, Ryan in the scene, though, really puts Michael in his place and everyone he's like, Hey, you know what? Enough. This is inappropriate and it stops right now. And the whole bullpen, it's like, you could hear a pin drop. We're like, Oh, my God. And then Michael has this fantastic talking
说不。他说这太明显了。是的，山羊胡太多了。整个造型非常像戈登·盖柯，你知道，电影《华尔街》。就像，你知道，瑞安现在认为他是纽约之王。是的。BJ说他总是顺着这样的提议。然后他说，举个例子，即将到来的金发。哦，是的。是的，瑞安在这一切结束前会经历几个造型。好吧，瑞安在场景中，确实让迈克尔和每个人都各就各位，他说，嘿，你知道吗？够了。这不合适，现在就停止。整个办公区，就像，你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。我们就像，天哪。然后迈克尔有了这个奇妙的谈话
head. I just loved it so much. He's like, yeah, maybe, you know, maybe he spoke to me like that. But there was a twinkle in his eye. And that twinkle said, dude, we're friends. And you know me. And I'd never take you for granted in a million years. I miss you. I love you. And then he's like, he goes on and on. He's like, his words, not mine. This episode, in addition to having great facial expressions from Paul has amazing Michael talking heads. They're so good. Well, now everyone's going to meet in the conference room so that Ryan can unveil his Dunder Mifflin infinity program. I have to point out something. First of all, where did the giant TV screen come from? It's not in there when the party planning committee is setting up. Secondly, you might notice there's no more
头。我太喜欢它了。他说，是的，也许，你知道，也许他那样对我说话。但他的眼睛里闪烁着光芒。那光芒说，伙计，我们是朋友。而且你了解我。我永远不会认为你是理所当然的。我想你。我爱你。然后他说，他继续说。他说，他的话，不是我的。这一集，除了保罗有很棒的面部表情外，还有很棒的迈克尔谈话头。它们太棒了。好吧，现在每个人都要在会议室见面，这样瑞安就可以揭开他的邓德·米夫林无限计划。我必须指出一件事。首先，巨大的电视屏幕是从哪里来的？当派对策划委员会设置时，它不在那里。其次，你可能会注意到墙上没有
banner on the wall, because there's a deleted scene where as they all come in on the banner, Kelly has written, she's scratched out Ryan. And it says, welcome back asshole. And Michael runs up to it and quickly rips it down. So Ryan won't see it. That is amazing. Well, in this scene, Michael announces two pretty big things. Number one, all essential personnel will be receiving an office blackberry phone. And second, we are soon to be launching the Dunder Mifflin infinity website that is going to streamline ordering. It's going to streamline efficiency. These are his two big announcements. Yeah, he says the company is going to get younger and sleeker. And this starts a Creed storyline that is so fantastic. Creed played this so well.
横幅了，因为有一个删除的场景，当他们都进来时，在横幅上，凯利写了，她划掉了瑞安。上面写着，欢迎回来混蛋。迈克尔跑过去，迅速把它撕下来。所以瑞安不会看到它。那太神奇了。好吧，在这个场景中，迈克尔宣布了两件相当大的事情。第一，所有必要人员都将收到一部办公室黑莓手机。第二，我们很快就要推出邓德·米夫林无限网站，这将简化订购。它将简化效率。这是他的两个大公告。是的，他说公司会变得更年轻、更时尚。这开启了一个克里德的故事线，太棒了。克里德演得太好了。
His reaction to the words younger, sleeker, he starts looking around. And then he goes up to Ryan at the end. He's like, when's this a new website launch? And then he's like, cool beans. Like he's trying to be hip or something. Well, he runs into Michael's office after the meeting. And he's like, you realize what this means, right? You, me, Sammy, Phyllis, the chick you hit with your car, we're all goners. Who is Sammy? Who is Sammy? Who does Creed think Sammy is? I don't know. Did he mean Stanley? Probably. Also, he has sat across from Meredith for years and couldn't think of her name. It's incredible. It's just great. Well, he calls my character Andrea the office bitch. So Sammy is probably Stanley. So now we have a very cute scene back
他对年轻、时尚这些词的反应，他开始环顾四周。然后他在最后走到瑞安身边。他说，这个新网站什么时候发布？然后他说，酷豆子。就像他试图变得时髦之类的。好吧，他在会议后跑进迈克尔的办公室。他说，你意识到这意味着什么，对吧？你，我，萨米，菲利斯，那个被你车撞的女孩，我们都完了。谁是萨米？谁是萨米？克里德认为萨米是谁？我不知道。他是指斯坦利吗？可能。此外，他坐在梅雷迪思对面多年，却想不起她的名字。这太不可思议了。这太棒了。好吧，他称我的角色安德里亚为办公室婊子。所以萨米可能是斯坦利。所以现在我们有一个非常可爱的场景回到
in the flirt room, the flirt room, break room, Jim and Pam are eating lunch together. And Jim's like, I can't believe I, you know, didn't tell you this is going to blow your mind. And he tells Pam that Dwight and Angela are dating. And Pam's like, um, yeah, I already knew that. It's been like a long time since before your barbecue, she says. Yeah. And then I love this. This next moment is just titled Phyllis Sass. Phyllis walks in and says, sorry, I didn't know you guys were in here. And Jim says, oh, we're just sitting here and Phyllis goes, couldn't see your hands. What? What is she applying? First of all, she knew they were in there. Okay. So she knew they were in there. She went to find Pam to tell her this information. Secondly, couldn't see
在休息室，休息室，休息室，吉姆和帕姆正在一起吃午饭。吉姆说，我真不敢相信我，你知道，没告诉你这件事，这会让你大吃一惊的。他告诉帕姆，德怀特和安吉拉在约会。帕姆说，嗯，是的，我早就知道了。她说，这已经是很久以前的事了，在你的烧烤聚会之前。是的。然后我喜欢这个。接下来的这一刻被命名为“菲利斯的刻薄”。菲利斯走进来，说，抱歉，我不知道你们在这里。吉姆说，哦，我们只是坐在这里，菲利斯说，没看见你们的手。什么？她在暗示什么？首先，她知道他们在里面。好吧。所以她知道他们在里面。她去找帕姆就是为了告诉她这个消息。其次，没看见
your hands. Well, and then John does this awesome move with his hands. It where he shows them the camera like they're so clearly right here. I loved that moment. That was a Krasinski special right there. No, it was perfect. And then Phyllis with the smile, Sass with a smile is like, you know, I'm glad you guys are dating. But Pam, when we get a new client, you have to just send it to, you know, the first available salesperson, not whoever you're sleeping with that week. That week. That week. It's like Phyllis and Angela both are in cahoots this episode because Pam is the office mattress. Well, Angela, I'm calling this a fan sass catch from Sneha G. She points out the major Phyllis sass as well. But she added this.
你们的手。嗯，然后约翰用他的手做了一个很棒的动作。他向摄像机展示它们，就像它们明明就在这里一样。我喜欢那一刻。那绝对是卡拉辛斯基的特别表演。不，这太完美了。然后菲利斯带着微笑，带着刻薄的微笑说，你知道，我很高兴你们在约会。但是帕姆，当我们有新客户时，你必须把它交给，你知道，第一个有空的销售人员，而不是你那周正在睡觉的那个人。那周。那周。就像菲利斯和安吉拉在这一集中串通一气一样，因为帕姆是办公室的“公共床垫”。好吧，安吉拉，我把这称为来自斯内哈·G的粉丝刻薄捕捉。她也指出了菲利斯主要的刻薄之处。但她补充了这一点。
According to Phyllis, Pam is in charge of assigning clients to salesmen randomly. Well, according to my husband, who's in a similar kind of office, this is a lot of power given to one person. That is not how the customers are typically assigned to salespeople. The assignment is based on the client's zip code or county to ensure that there is always a clear rule regarding this assignment. Well, I have to say, after college, before I moved to Los Angeles, I was the only receptionist slash administrative assistant at a small marine audio company in Missouri. And marine audio. They made like water resistant, waterproof stereo systems for boats. Thank you. I needed clarity. Thank you. You're welcome. Okay. Whenever we got a cold call
据菲利斯说，帕姆负责随机分配客户给销售人员。嗯，据我丈夫说，他在类似的办公室工作，这赋予了一个人很大的权力。这通常不是客户分配给销售人员的方式。分配是基于客户的邮政编码或县，以确保关于这种分配始终有明确的规则。嗯，我必须说，大学毕业后，在我搬到洛杉矶之前，我是密苏里州一家小型海洋音响公司的唯一接待员兼行政助理。海洋音响。他们制造类似防水的船用立体声系统。谢谢。我需要澄清一下。谢谢。不客气。好吧。每当我们接到冷呼叫
for marine audio, right? I would just transfer them randomly to an available sales associate. It was kind of my call. Wow. Yeah, it didn't come up very often. But every once in a while, we would get a cold call. Pam's job has this weird hierarchy. First of all, she has to ask Angela for petty cash. And then she has these sad plants and this candy that Angela expects her to put out. But now we find out she passes on clients to the sales department. Yeah. And she's Michael's secretary. It's very layered. You know, I based a lot of my Pam stuff off of this job that I had at this marine audio place. It was about the same number of people as Dunder Mifflin. There was a warehouse where we shipped all the orders.
关于海洋音响，对吧？我就会把他们随机转给一个有空的销售助理。这算是我的决定。哇。是的，这种情况并不常发生。但偶尔，我们会接到一个冷呼叫。帕姆的工作有这种奇怪的等级制度。首先，她必须向安吉拉要零用钱。然后她有这些可怜的植物和安吉拉希望她摆出来的糖果。但现在我们发现她把客户转给了销售部门。是的。而且她是迈克尔的秘书。这非常有层次。你知道，我很多帕姆的东西都是基于我在那个海洋音响公司的工作。人数和邓德·米夫林差不多。有一个仓库，我们负责运送所有订单。
And I was literally Pam. I made the coffee in the morning. I answered the phones. I did everyone's administrative work. Did you date anyone there? I did not. Smart. Yeah. I did not date anyone at marine audio. Okay. Well, now we have a gym talking head. And he says that is why we waited so long to tell people. Did you notice Jim is facing the bullpen with his back to the outside? No, because his future's in the bullpen. His future is Pam and she's out there. Yeah. He now has a future at Dunder Mifflin. Yes. In his heart. It's very interesting. I know. I want to go back one second. Okay. Just one second. I have been wondering, for several episodes now out loud, when did Jim and Pam tell one another about their shared
我简直就是帕姆。我早上煮咖啡。我接电话。我做每个人的行政工作。你在那里和人约会过吗？我没有。聪明。是的。我没有在海洋音响和任何人约会。好吧。现在我们有一个吉姆的采访镜头。他说这就是为什么我们等了这么久才告诉别人。你注意到吉姆面对着办公区，背对着外面吗？不，因为他的未来在办公区。他的未来是帕姆，她就在外面。是的。他现在在邓德·米夫林有了未来。是的。在他心里。这很有趣。我知道。我想回去一秒钟。好吧。就一秒钟。我一直在想，几集以来都在大声问，吉姆和帕姆是什么时候告诉对方他们共同
knowledge of Dwight and Angela? And it is finally revealed in this episode. It's right now at work. What? Do we believe this? This took forever. No, I believe it because I think the beginning of them falling in love and finally getting to be together, it was so special to them. I mean, I just feel like they were really absorbed with one another. And now, now they're at the point they've been dating a few months where they're like, oh, by the way, did you know, you know what I mean? I think they're at that place. I think they were sort of in that fog of love for a few weeks. I buy it. You do not buy it by your sassy. I think it would have been the first thing I would have said on our first dinner date. I don't think so. Hey, by the way.
关于德怀特和安吉拉的秘密？这一集终于揭晓了。就在现在，在工作中。什么？我们相信这个吗？这花了好久。不，我相信，因为我认为他们坠入爱河并最终能够在一起的开始，对他们来说太特别了。我的意思是，我只是觉得他们真的沉浸在彼此之中。现在，现在他们已经约会几个月了，他们会说，哦，顺便问一下，你知道吗，你知道我的意思吗？我认为他们处于那个阶段。我认为他们有几周时间处于那种爱的迷雾中。我信。你不信，因为你很刻薄。我觉得那会是我第一次晚餐约会时说的第一件事。我不这么认为。嘿，顺便说一下。
I don't think after years of loving this guy, the first time you're alone with him, he's like, wait, wait, wait, I'll kiss you in a second. First, we need to talk about Dwight and Angela. You're probably right. All right. Well, now Michael and Ryan are in Michael's office. Ryan is so busy typing on his Blackberry. Do you remember at this time, Rain and I both had Blackberries in real life and we were Ryan? We were constantly on our Blackberries. We were so annoying. I think Brian Baumgartner had one too. Excuse me. I had one. This, we all had one. That's what you had. You had a Blackberry. There were no smartphones. You had a Blackberry and you did not take pictures with your phone, which is why you and I have so many photos, like old-timey
我不认为在爱了这个男人多年之后，第一次和他单独相处，他会说，等等，等等，等等，我一会儿再吻你。首先，我们需要谈谈德怀特和安吉拉。你可能是对的。好吧。现在迈克尔和瑞安在迈克尔的办公室里。瑞安正忙着在黑莓手机上打字。你还记得当时吗，瑞安和我在现实生活中都有黑莓手机，我们就是瑞安？我们一直在用黑莓手机。我们太烦人了。我想布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳也有一个。抱歉。我有一个。这个，我们都有一个。这就是你有的。你有一个黑莓手机。那时没有智能手机。你有一个黑莓手机，你不用手机拍照，这就是为什么你和我有很多照片，像老式的
photos, because we would bring our cameras to the set and we would take pictures and then we would go to the mall to that kiosk and we would develop our photos. Yep. It's true. But we could now do emails at work while we were standing between scenes because we had our Blackberries. Yes. And our thumbs were so fast. We got so good at it. And I was a holdout. I did not get the iPhone to way late because I was so attached to my Blackberry. I was the same. I really resented the smartphone screen thing where I, like, pressed on the screen. I was real into the, like, the tangible button thing. I kept on my phone for a long time when I finally got an iPhone. You know how you can choose the sound so it goes click, click, click, click, click, click, click.
照片，因为我们会带相机去片场，我们会拍照，然后我们会去商场的那个亭子去冲洗照片。是的。这是真的。但我们现在可以在工作时在场景之间站着发邮件，因为我们有黑莓手机。是的。而且我们的拇指太快了。我们变得非常擅长。而我是一个坚持者。我直到很晚才买iPhone，因为我太依赖我的黑莓手机了。我也一样。我真的很讨厌智能手机的屏幕，就是那种我按在屏幕上的感觉。我真的很喜欢那种有形按钮的东西。当我最终买了一部iPhone时，我用了很久我的手机。你知道你可以选择声音，让它发出咔哒、咔哒、咔哒、咔哒、咔哒、咔哒、咔哒的声音。
Yeah. Because I was attached to the sound. Well, Michael in this scene wants to make sure that they're on the same page. It's business as usual. And Ryan is like, no, it's the opposite of business as usual. We're literally throwing out the old playbook. We're starting over. We want a younger, faster company, which leads us into just an incredible talking head by Michael. Just incredible. Yeah. He, I mean, they had a foreign exchange student that lived with him. And he said, we called him my brother because he was, and then he went back to what was formally Yugoslavia and he took all of Michael's blue jeans. Yeah. Michael had to wear shorts all winter. Why Jenna? Why? Why couldn't his mother buy him any replacement blue jeans for the winter?
是的。因为我依恋那个声音。好吧，迈克尔在这一幕中想确保他们达成共识。一切照旧。瑞安说，不，这与一切照旧相反。我们实际上是在抛弃旧的剧本。我们要重新开始。我们想要一家更年轻、更快的公司，这引出了迈克尔一段令人难以置信的采访镜头。简直不可思议。是的，他，我的意思是，他们有一个住在他家的外国交换生。他说，我们叫他我的兄弟，因为他是，然后他回到了前南斯拉夫，他拿走了迈克尔所有的蓝色牛仔裤。是的。迈克尔整个冬天都不得不穿短裤。为什么珍娜？为什么？为什么他妈妈不能给他买任何替换的蓝色牛仔裤过冬？
I don't know, but we had several people write in and wonder if this is why Michael covets his blue jeans today and why he dry cleans them because of this traumatic event where this foreign exchange student stole all his jeans. And his mother punished him by not letting him buy any new ones. But yeah, he says that is what Ryan is like, a fake brother who steals your jeans. Well, Jenna, we should probably take a break. Before we do, I want you to know there was a deleted scene that would have happened in this area of the episode where Michael gets a message and he says to Pam, hey, can you put that in my blackberry? I'm too busy right now to input it. Will you put that in my blackberry? And he makes a big speech. So it's like, I am using
我不知道，但我们有几个人写信来想知道这是否就是迈克尔今天垂涎他的蓝色牛仔裤，以及为什么他干洗它们的原因，是因为这个外国交换生偷了他所有牛仔裤的创伤性事件。而他妈妈惩罚他，不让他买任何新的。但是的，他说这就是瑞安的样子，一个偷你牛仔裤的假兄弟。好吧，珍娜，我们可能应该休息一下。在我们休息之前，我想让你知道这一集在这个区域有一个被删减的场景，迈克尔收到一条消息，他对帕姆说，嘿，你能把它放进我的黑莓手机里吗？我现在太忙了，没法输入。你能把它放进我的黑莓手机里吗？然后他发表了一大通演讲。所以就像，我正在使用
my blackberry. Pam, please enter that in my blackberry. And then there's a Pam talking head and she goes, um, yeah, Michael doesn't know how to use his blackberry. And so when he says for me to put it in his blackberry, he means for me to write it on a post-it and stick it on top of the blackberry. And then you see, you see his phone is covered, his blackberry is covered with all these little miniature post-it notes, stickies. You would love that. I would love that. That's the best way to give you a message on your blackberry. I know, just put a sticky on it. All right, well, we'll take a break and we will be back with some Kelly Ryan drama. Oh man, Kelly, Kelly's in rare form. So now we're in the annex and Kelly is telling Ryan, you know what,
我的黑莓手机。帕姆，请把它输入我的黑莓手机。然后有一个帕姆的采访镜头，她说，嗯，是的，迈克尔不知道怎么用他的黑莓手机。所以当他说让我把它放进他的黑莓手机时，他的意思是让我把它写在便利贴上，贴在黑莓手机上面。然后你看到，你看到他的手机被覆盖了，他的黑莓手机上贴满了这些小小的便利贴。你会喜欢那个的。我会喜欢的。那是给你的黑莓手机留言的最好方式。我知道，只要贴个便利贴就行了。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后会有一些凯利和瑞安的戏份。哦天哪，凯利，凯利的状态非常罕见。现在我们在附楼，凯利正在告诉瑞安，你知道吗，
I am doing great. In fact, I am dating a lot of guys and he's like Kelly and she's like, what? She's like so pissed. And of course, Toby, Toby is listening to the whole conversation. Well, then Kelly says she's pregnant. Yeah. And then she has a talking head where she just shakes her head now. It made me laugh out loud. It was so funny. And then, and then this is how she gets Ryan to go to dinner with her. He's like, okay, she's like, I'm keeping the baby. And he's like, let's just, I can't talk about this now. Let's go to dinner. And then she has a talking head where she's like, we have a date. Yes. Well, also in this conversation, Ryan says, I did take our relationship seriously. Karen asked me out six months ago and I said no. Oh, he's such a liar.
我过得很好。事实上，我正在和很多男人约会，他就像凯利，她就像，什么？她气疯了。当然，托比，托比正在听整个谈话。好吧，然后凯利说她怀孕了。是的。然后她有一个采访镜头，她只是摇了摇头。这让我大声笑了出来。太搞笑了。然后，然后这就是她让瑞安和她一起去吃晚餐的方式。他说，好吧，她说，我要留下这个孩子。他说，我们只是，我现在不能谈这个。我们去吃晚餐吧。然后她有一个采访镜头，她说，我们有约会了。是的。好吧，在这次谈话中，瑞安说，我确实认真对待我们的关系。凯伦六个月前约我出去，我说不。哦，他真是个骗子。
He's such a liar. Well, this was a fan question from Hannah Colson. Do we think Karen really asked Ryan out or was he just saying that to make Kelly jealous? No, he was trying to show Kelly how committed he was. The truth is he hit on Karen and asked her out. And they talked about it in the bathroom in women's appreciation. That's right. It came up. Jim was like, yes, she told me about that. So no, Ryan's being a big old liar right here. Well, we got a letter from Renata in Brazil about the Ryan and Kelly relationship. Okay, Renata, she was very passionate about it. And here is what she had to say. Okay. She says, I love this episode so much, but I just need to make a comment about Kelly and Ryan's relationship and how relatable it can be and how it shouldn't be.
他真是个骗子。好吧，这是一个来自汉娜·科尔森的粉丝问题。我们认为凯伦真的约过瑞安吗，还是他只是为了让凯利嫉妒才这么说的？不，他是在向凯利展示他有多么忠诚。事实是他勾引了凯伦并约她出去。他们在“女性欣赏”那一集的洗手间里谈过这件事。没错。提到了。吉姆说，是的，她告诉过我这件事。所以不，瑞安在这里是个大骗子。好吧，我们收到了一封来自巴西雷纳塔的关于瑞安和凯利关系的信。好吧，雷纳塔，她对此非常热情。这就是她要说的。好吧。她说，我非常喜欢这一集，但我只是需要对凯利和瑞安的关系发表评论，以及它有多么令人共鸣，以及它本不该如此。
I've met a lot of Ryan's in my life and ladies, it is not worth it. I just want to send some love to all of you and say that you deserve someone who's going to put your love on top. So I hope that this crazy relationship will teach you something about what not to accept because you deserve more. I don't know. Maybe someone out there needs to hear this. That's from Renata. Renata, applause. You're right. You're absolutely right. Another thing going on during the scene is we quickly see Phyllis and Stanley trying to figure out the Blackberry. And Jenna, if you go to 12 minutes 41 seconds in the deep background, you can just see me surfing the internet. You see me like scrolling through. I jot something down. I scroll through some more. I'm probably
我在生活中遇到过很多瑞安，女士们，这不值得。我只是想给你们所有人送去一些爱，并说你们值得拥有一个会把你们的爱放在首位的人。所以我希望这段疯狂的关系能教会你们一些关于不要接受什么的东西，因为你们值得更多。我不知道。也许外面有人需要听到这个。这是雷纳塔说的。雷纳塔，鼓掌。你是对的。你绝对是对的。在这一幕中发生的另一件事是，我们很快看到菲利斯和斯坦利试图弄清楚黑莓手机。珍娜，如果你在12分41秒看深背景，你可以看到我在上网。你看到我像在滚动浏览。我记下了一些东西。我滚动浏览更多。我可能在
shopping. That's amazing. Well, then we move into Angela and Dwight having another one of their back-to-back conversations in the kitchen. Yes, but do you know who we have to thank for this moment? Who? Pam. Why? In a deleted scene that would have come right before this, Pam is going to give Angela some advice. Sam, I'm going to play the clip. He tried to give me a new cat to replace sprinkles as if you could replace sprinkles. He just has a hard time expressing himself. Well, it's really upsetting me. You probably noticed, but this last week I've been a raging bitch. What should I do? Look, there's a lot of good parts of this relationship, right?
购物。太棒了。好吧，然后我们进入安吉拉和德怀特在厨房里进行的又一次背靠背谈话。是的，但你知道我们要感谢谁带来这一刻吗？谁？帕姆。为什么？在一个本应出现在这之前的被删减场景中，帕姆要给安吉拉一些建议。萨姆，我要播放这段剪辑。他试图给我一只新猫来代替斯普林克尔斯，好像你能代替斯普林克尔斯一样。他只是很难表达自己。嗯，这真的让我很心烦。你可能注意到了，但这最后一周我一直是个暴躁的婊子。我该怎么办？听着，这段关系中有很多好的部分，对吧？
None of your business. Right. Well, just try to focus on those. Why don't you guys go out to dinner tonight and talk about whatever you always talk about? Maybe you're right. Yeah. Yeah. I said maybe. So yes, Angela and Pam met at the elevators and Pam gives her this relationship advice. I am so sad that did not make it in. That was delightful. It was so fun. It was so fun. So Angela actually takes Pam's advice and is like, okay, there's something worth fighting for here. I'll ask him out to dinner and maybe I'll be able to forgive him and I'll start with this dinner.
不关你的事。对。好吧，试着专注于那些。为什么你们今晚不去吃晚餐，谈谈你们总是谈论的事情呢？也许你是对的。是的。是的。我说也许。所以是的，安吉拉和帕姆在电梯处见面，帕姆给了她这个关系建议。我很难过它没有被放进去。那太令人愉快了。太有趣了。太有趣了。所以安吉拉真的听了帕姆的建议，觉得，好吧，这里有什么值得争取的。我会约他去吃晚餐，也许我能原谅他，我会从这顿晚餐开始。
Well, Dwight offers to make you dinner. He says he will cook you noodles and cauliflower with a side of baked potato. I want you to know, Angela, for whatever reason, this caused me to Google noodles and cauliflower. I just saw it as like she loves her starches and she's a vegetarian. What'd you find? Noodles and cauliflower is a very popular vegetarian dish. Oh. The New York Times cooking page had a recipe that looks so good. I think I'm going to make it. Oh, send it to me. Guys, Google noodles and cauliflower. Okay. It's a bonanza. It's fantastic. I can't wait. My Lord, who knew? Well, now we have what I think is such a deliciously
好吧，德怀特主动提出为你做晚餐。他说他会为你煮面条和花椰菜，配上烤土豆。我想让你知道，安吉拉，不管什么原因，这让我去谷歌搜索了面条和花椰菜。我只是觉得她喜欢淀粉，而且她是素食主义者。你发现了什么？面条和花椰菜是一道非常受欢迎的素食菜肴。哦。《纽约时报》烹饪页面有一个看起来很好吃的食谱。我想我要做它。哦，发给我。伙计们，谷歌搜索面条和花椰菜。好吧。这是一个宝库。太棒了。我等不及了。天哪，谁知道呢？好吧，现在我们有了我认为非常美味的
tacky scene. It is a tacky off, if you will, between Jan and Ryan. Oh, it's so good. He's like, well, you know, we should probably talk about the elephant in the room. I got your job and she's like, didn't get my job, not my salary, but you'll get there and it's super tacky. And then Ryan says, Scranton suits you. And Jan says, best decision I ever made. Ryan says, you were let go. And then Jan goes, and she looks maniacal. She says, you know what? Love the beard. Keep it forever. And scratches his beard. And that makes him super insecure about his beard. I thought it was amazing. Love the beard. Keep it forever. Well, did you notice what she's wearing in the scene? It's a velour jumpsuit, right? A juicy couture velour jumpsuit, which were all the rage at this time.
俗气的场景。如果你愿意的话，这是简和瑞安之间的俗气对决。哦，太棒了。他说，嗯，你知道，我们可能应该谈谈房间里的大象。我得到了你的工作，她说，没得到我的工作，不是我的薪水，但你会达到的，这超级俗气。然后瑞安说，斯克兰顿适合你。简说，我做过的最好的决定。瑞安说，你被解雇了。然后简说，她看起来很疯狂。她说，你知道吗？喜欢这胡子。永远留着它。然后抓他的胡子。这让他对自己的胡子超级不自信。我觉得这太棒了。喜欢这胡子。永远留着它。好吧，你注意到她在这一幕中穿什么了吗？是天鹅绒连体裤，对吧？Juicy Couture天鹅绒连体裤，在当时非常流行。
Yeah, they said juicy across the butt. Do you remember that? Some of them did, not all of them, but the zipper for the hoodie, because it was a hoodie and pants set. The zipper, it had a little J as it's, what do you call that thing you hold in your thumb and finger to zipper? The zipper toggle? Yeah, is it called a zipper toggle? I don't know. That's what I call it. Yeah, well, it was a J. I remember there was this really, really popular thing, which was that brides would change into a white juicy couture jumpsuit after the wedding, some point during the reception, and they would get it embroidered with like just married or like Mrs, whatever their new last name is going to be. And I might have done that when Lee and I got married. I might have
是的，它们在屁股上写着Juicy。你还记得吗？有些有，不是全部，但连帽衫的拉链，因为它是一套连帽衫和裤子。拉链，它有一个小J作为它的，你叫那个你用拇指和手指拿着拉链的东西叫什么？拉链头？是的，它叫拉链头吗？我不知道。这就是我叫它的方式。是的，好吧，它是一个J。我记得有一件非常非常流行的事情，就是新娘会在婚礼后，在招待会的某个时候换上一件白色的Juicy Couture连体裤，她们会让人绣上类似“刚结婚”或者“某某夫人”，无论她们的新姓氏是什么。我和李结婚时可能做过那个。我可能
ordered one of these white. But you didn't wear it. I was at your reception. You never came out in your your little jogging outfit. Well, Angela, there was like an after after party for the reception for everyone who stayed at the hotel. You left at a certain point. I look early. You were annoyed with me a little bit, but I was. I don't remember being annoyed. You just said, and you can't leave yet. And I was like, Jenna, because I, you know, I had a toddler. I was like, it doesn't matter what time I go to bed. She's going to wake up at the same time. Were you there for the miniature burgers and fries because those came out at midnight? And I think that might have been why I wanted you to stay. There were also miniature shakes because you know I like miniature
订购了其中一件白色的。但你没穿它。我在你的招待会上。你从来没有穿着你的慢跑装出来。好吧，安吉拉，招待会之后还有一个给所有住在酒店的人准备的派对。你在某个时候离开了。我看起来很早。你对我有点恼火，但我当时是。我不记得我恼火了。你只是说，你还不能走。我说，珍娜，因为我，你知道，我有一个蹒跚学步的孩子。我说，我几点睡觉没关系。她会在同一时间醒来。你在那里吃迷你汉堡和薯条吗，因为那些是在午夜出来的？我想那可能就是我想要你留下的原因。还有迷你奶昔，因为你知道我喜欢迷你
foods. I know you do. No, I like it when you take a regular burger and you just shrink it on down to baby size. I know. Little fries, little fry containers, a little shake with a tiny straw. I left around 1030 and you were like, what? You left at 1030? I had a young kid. Nothing had happened yet. I had a young kid. I had to get home. I had a sitter. I had a sitter who I said I'd be home by 11 and you said to me, you're like, Angela, we're going to watch the sun come up. And I don't know if you know this about yourself, but every once in a while you're determined to party until sunrise. Yes. And I've done it a handful of times and it's always the best time. I don't do it too much. I keep it as like a special treat. My wedding night was one of them and around 2.30 in the morning,
食物。我知道你喜欢。不，我喜欢你拿一个普通的汉堡，然后把它缩小到婴儿大小。我知道。小薯条，小薯条盒，带小吸管的小奶昔。我在10点半左右离开，你就像，什么？你在10点半离开？我有一个小孩。什么都没发生呢。我有一个小孩。我必须回家。我有一个保姆。我有一个保姆，我说过我会在11点前回家，你对我说，你就像，安吉拉，我们要看太阳升起。我不知道你是否了解自己这一点，但每隔一段时间你就决心聚会到日出。是的。我做过几次，总是最开心的时光。我做得不多。我把它当作一种特别的款待。我的新婚之夜就是其中之一，在凌晨2点半左右，
I changed into my white velour, juicy couture, custom embroidered, just married, Mrs. Kirk jumpsuit. Well, that's so cute. I want to see a picture of that. I did get a cute little jacket that I wore at the end of my wedding as I left that said Mrs. Snyder on the back. I remember that. Yeah. Okay. So I didn't know that was a thing and I didn't even know you did it. Oh my God. Well, now you know. Now I know. I'll show you pictures. Yeah, I want to see. Well, now Jan and Michael are having lunch and Jan is going to explain ageism to Michael, which is just wonderful. It's so good. And there is a deleted scene that they cut to where Michael says to Dwight, I need you to find out everything you can about something for
我换上了我的白色天鹅绒、Juicy Couture、定制刺绣的“刚结婚，柯克夫人”连体裤。好吧，那太可爱了。我想看那张照片。我确实在婚礼结束时穿了一件可爱的小夹克，上面写着斯奈德夫人。我记得那个。是的。好吧，所以我不知道那是一回事，我甚至不知道你做了那个。天哪。好吧，现在你知道了。现在我知道了。我会给你看照片。是的，我想看。好吧，现在简和迈克尔正在吃午饭，简要向迈克尔解释年龄歧视，这真是太棒了。太好了。有一个被删减的场景，他们切到了那里，迈克尔对德怀特说，我需要你找出关于某件事的一切，关于
me. Ready? It's called ageism. Write it down. And he's like, I don't know what it is. I need to find all the details. I don't know if Jan is just pranking me or if it's a real thing, but I need you to find it all out. I need you to do it in an hour. Well, Michael has this great line where he's like, wait, are you saying that old people have the same rights as young people? And Jan's like, yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So fan catch from Sadie S in this scene. Hi, Jenna and Angela. I'm Sadie. I'm 14 and I love the office and your podcast. Thank you, Sadie. At 15 minutes, 10 seconds, when Michael is having lunch with Jan, it looks like Michael has a personal homemade salad dressing. It is on his desk in a jar with his face on it, a picture of a salad,
我。准备好了吗？它叫年龄歧视。写下来。他就像，我不知道那是什么。我需要找出所有细节。我不知道简是在跟我开玩笑还是它是真实存在的东西，但我需要你全部找出来。我需要你在一个小时内完成。好吧，迈克尔有这句很棒的台词，他说，等等，你是说老年人和年轻人有同样的权利吗？简说，是的。是的。是的。是的。所以来自萨迪·S的粉丝捕捉，在这一幕中。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我是萨迪。我14岁，我喜欢《办公室》和你们的播客。谢谢你，萨迪。在15分10秒，当迈克尔和简吃午饭时，看起来迈克尔有一种个人的自制沙拉酱。它在他的桌子上，在一个罐子里，上面有他的脸，一张沙拉的照片，
and it says, Great Scott, just like the production company of Threat Level Midnight. She said, I couldn't stop laughing when I noticed this. Who thought to make this prop? Oh, Sadie, you and I are on the same page. I have a post-it note. 15 minutes, 10 seconds, I put salad dressing. I think it's a callback from the Fun Run episode. But wasn't that a deleted scene? Yes. So guys, there's a deleted scene and it's so good. It's in Fun Run. Michael has this talking head where he's talking about his charity for rabies and he says, look, it's struggling. And he says, what do I look like? Paul Newman. And then he goes, actually, that's not a bad example because people have told me, I look like Paul Newman. You know,
上面写着，“伟大的斯科特”，就像《午夜威胁》的制作公司一样。她说，当我注意到这一点时，我无法停止大笑。谁想到做这个道具的？哦，萨迪，你和我想法一样。我有一个便利贴。15分10秒，我写了沙拉酱。我认为这是来自“趣味跑”那一集的回调。但那不是一个被删减的场景吗？是的。所以伙计们，有一个被删减的场景，它太棒了。它在“趣味跑”里。迈克尔有一个采访镜头，他在谈论他的狂犬病慈善机构，他说，看，它很挣扎。他说，我看起来像什么？保罗·纽曼。然后他说，实际上，那不是一个坏例子，因为人们告诉我，我看起来像保罗·纽曼。你知道，
it's the eyes and the face. And he said, also, I make my own salad dressing. He mixes Newman's ranch with Newman's Italian and sells it at a flea market for a loss. He could make a profit on it if he changed one of the ingredients to wishbone, but he won't do it. That is incredible. So I think that is his mixture of Newman's ranch and Newman's Italian. Well, what I like to think is that, you know, once something has been established on the show, we like to track it. They're eating a salad. So of course, they're going to put his salad dressing out. I bet when we filmed this episode, we didn't yet know that that was going to be cut out from Fun Run because they were still in post-production on it. And that's why the salad
是眼睛和脸。他说，还有，我自己做沙拉酱。他把纽曼的牧场酱和纽曼的意大利酱混合，在跳蚤市场上亏本出售。如果他把其中一种成分换成Wishbone，他就能盈利，但他不会那样做。这太不可思议了。所以我认为那是他纽曼牧场酱和纽曼意大利酱的混合物。好吧，我喜欢认为，你知道，一旦节目中确立了某件事，我们喜欢追踪它。他们正在吃沙拉。所以当然，他们会把他的沙拉酱拿出来。我敢打赌，当我们拍摄这一集时，我们还不知道那会从“趣味跑”中剪掉，因为他们还在后期制作中。这就是为什么沙拉
dressing remains. Yeah, that's right. I totally believe that. And you guys, as they continue talking and eating their salad, I want you to know at 15 minutes, 50 seconds, I think Steve, as an actor, makes a very bold choice. The broccoli? He eats a piece of broccoli. I mean, you can't talk after that. It's a good thing the scene ended. That would have taken a long time to chew. And I feel like I see a moment, not Michael Scott. I see Steve Carell go, oh, crap, I just put this piece of broccoli in my mouth. I think you're right. I do too. I think you see a moment of regret. Well, now, Angela, someone enters the office with jet black hair. We don't know who because the camera is tracking
酱还在。是的，没错。我完全相信这一点。伙计们，当他们继续谈话和吃沙拉时，我想让你们知道在15分50秒，我认为史蒂夫，作为一个演员，做出了一个非常大胆的选择。西兰花？他吃了一块西兰花。我的意思是，那之后你没法说话。场景结束真是太好了。那会花很长时间咀嚼。我觉得我看到了一个瞬间，不是迈克尔·斯科特。我看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，哦，该死，我刚把这块西兰花放进嘴里。我想你是对的。我也这么认为。我想你看到了一个后悔的瞬间。好吧，现在，安吉拉，有人带着乌黑的头发进入办公室。我们不知道是谁，因为摄像机正在追踪
him behind his head through the office. And it is revealed to be Creed. He wants you to know he's only 30. I mean, well, in November, he'll be 30. He'll be 30. Yeah. Yeah. In November. We got a lot of fan questions about this. Sharlia G., Catherine Otto, Kelly Hendricks, Andrea V., and Julie Brown all asked, did Creed really dye his hair for this episode? Well, we texted Creed. We did. We had a delightful text thread with him yesterday. It was so funny. I know. Well, he said that it was a vegetable dye that washed out completely no problem, but he suggested that we tell you all that it was a permanent dye that caused all of his hair to fall out so that he could possibly use this as evidence to sue him. Ferry, who would then
他在办公室里他头后的动作。结果发现是克里德。他想让你知道他只有30岁。我的意思是，好吧，在十一月，他会是30岁。他会是30岁。是的。是的。在十一月。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝问题。夏莉亚·G、凯瑟琳·奥托、凯利·亨德里克斯、安德里亚·V和朱莉·布朗都问，克里德真的为了这一集染了头发吗？好吧，我们给克里德发了短信。我们发了。我们昨天和他有一个愉快的短信串。太搞笑了。我知道。好吧，他说那是一种洗得干干净净的植物染料，没问题，但他建议我们告诉你们所有人那是一种永久性染料，导致他所有的头发都掉光了，这样他就可以利用这个作为证据来起诉他。费里，然后会
counter sue him for libel. And I was like, you're turning our podcast into a courtroom thriller. I think Creed yesterday was really tickled because he had a whole text thread with us where he went on and on about his different ideas of like a better story of how they dyed his hair. Yes. He was having a good time texting us. But the truth was, it was just a washout vegetable dye. Sorry, Creed. And of course, we find out in this conference room scene that Creed used all the ink from the printer. Yeah. He put the printer ink. There is a deleted scene, you know, where he has a mirror and he's filling in the spots he missed with the black Sharpie. Oh my gosh. I know. I know. Oh my goodness. Well, we might have to start a different text
反诉他诽谤。我说，你把我们的播客变成了法庭惊悚片。我想克里德昨天真的很开心，因为他有一个完整的短信串，他一直在谈论他关于如何染头发的更好故事的不同想法。是的。他发短信发得很开心。但事实是，那只是一种洗得掉的植物染料。抱歉，克里德。当然，我们在会议室这一幕中发现克里德用了打印机里所有的墨水。是的。他把打印机墨水。有一个被删减的场景，你知道，他拿着一面镜子，用黑色记号笔填补他漏掉的地方。天哪。我知道。我知道。天哪。好吧，我们可能不得不开始另一个短信
thread with him about that black Sharpie deleted scene because I need to know more. By the way, we not only had a text thread with Creed yesterday, just the three of us, we also had a lot of activity on our group office text thread. We were in like all texting each other at the storm. Yes. And I had a separate text thread with just the accountants going. Oh my gosh. We were text happy as a cast yesterday. I guess we were. Well, like Angela said, everyone is gathered in the conference room. Ryan enters to do his Blackberry tutorial, but Michael tells Ryan, I'm sorry, this is still my office. Have a seat. I could not believe that Ryan entertained this. I couldn't believe it. Yeah. I mean,
关于那个黑色记号笔被删减场景的串，因为我需要知道更多。顺便说一下，我们昨天不仅和克里德有短信串，只有我们三个，我们在我们的办公室群组短信串上也有很多活动。我们都在风暴中互相发短信。是的。我有一个单独的只有会计师的短信串。天哪。我们昨天作为一个演员阵容发短信发疯了。我想我们是。好吧，就像安吉拉说的，每个人都聚集在会议室。瑞安进来做他的黑莓手机教程，但迈克尔告诉瑞安，对不起，这仍然是我的办公室。请坐。我无法相信瑞安会接受这个。我无法相信。是的。我的意思是，
as soon as he saw the pictures on the wall, yeah, he was like, Oh, Michael, here we go. Here we go. It's the lady from Titanic. Mm hmm. The where's the beef lady? Yeah. And then the picture from big where they're dancing on the keyboard. Yes. And then the last one has been Kingsley. Yeah. And this is when Pam is like, why did you reuse the old photos? And Michael says, because the ink ran out of the printer. Yeah. And Creed kind of was like, huh, there's like, but then all of a sudden someone enters the room, just as Ryan has had enough enough in walks. Robert Dunder, one of the founders of Dunder Mifflin. How fantastic was that scene with him? It was so good. Oh man, I rewatched it like a few times because he's so
他一看到墙上的照片，是的，他就像，哦，迈克尔，我们开始吧。我们开始吧。那是《泰坦尼克号》里的女士。嗯哼。那是“牛肉在哪里”的女士。是的。然后是《飞越未来》里他们在键盘上跳舞的照片。是的。然后最后一张是金斯利。是的。这就是帕姆说，你为什么要重复使用旧照片？迈克尔说，因为打印机没墨了。是的。克里德有点像，哈，有，但突然有人进入房间，就在瑞安受够了的时候，罗伯特·邓德，邓德·米夫林的创始人之一走了进来。和他那一幕有多棒？太好了。哦天哪，我重看了好几次，因为他太
perfect. His delivery is spot on. Well, Robert Dunder was played by this actor named John Ingle. And this is the only episode that Robert Dunder appears in. But John Ingle starred on General Hospital. He played Patriarch Edward Quartermaine from 1993 to 2012. He did 485 episodes of General Hospital. Wow. He also did a ton of other television work. He was also an acting teacher at Beverly Hills High School from 1964 to 1985. And listen to who he taught while he was a teacher there. He taught Nicholas Cage, Albert Brooks, Swoosie Kurtz, David Schwimmer, and Jonathan Silverman, among others. He was also an active volunteer for Habitat for Humanity. He had five daughters and he passed away in 2012. Well, we were so fortunate to have him. He was such a
完美了。他的表演非常到位。好吧，罗伯特·邓德是由一位名叫约翰·英格尔的演员扮演的。这是罗伯特·邓德出现的唯一一集。但约翰·英格尔在《综合医院》中担任主角。他从1993年到2012年扮演族长爱德华·夸特曼。他演了485集《综合医院》。哇。他还做了很多其他电视工作。他还是比佛利山庄高中的表演老师，从1964年到1985年。听听他在那里当老师时教过谁。他教过尼古拉斯·凯奇、阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯、斯沃西·库尔茨、大卫·休默和乔纳森·西尔弗曼等人。他还是“仁人家园”的积极志愿者。他有五个女儿，于2012年去世。好吧，我们很幸运能拥有他。他是一位如此
seasoned actor and so, so delightful. And I love the scene. He goes on this very, very long meandering story. But the way he connects it all is so real and organic. And you guys, we have been there. We have all been there at that, you know, family gathering where someone gets up to talk and you're like, what, what are we talking about? Yeah, you ask some innocent question like, oh my gosh, where'd you get your sweater? And they're like, well, it was three years ago and it was raining that day. I remember. I remember because I just got my hair done and they gave me a plastic net to put over it. Yes. And my friend Cynthia called and she said, well, you know, Cynthia, she had lived abroad. And when she came back, she divorced and married that younger guy. Well, she did. But
经验丰富的演员，非常非常令人愉快。我喜欢这一幕。他讲了一个非常非常漫长的蜿蜒故事。但他连接这一切的方式是如此真实和有机。伙计们，我们去过那里。我们都去过那个，你知道，家庭聚会，有人站起来说话，你就像，什么，我们在谈论什么？是的，你问一些无辜的问题，比如，哦天哪，你的毛衣是从哪里买的？他们就像，嗯，那是三年前，那天在下雨。我记得。我记得，因为我刚做完头发，他们给了我一个塑料网罩在上面。是的。我的朋友辛西娅打电话说，嗯，你知道，辛西娅，她曾在国外生活。当她回来时，她离婚并嫁给了那个年轻的男人。好吧，她确实嫁了。但
first remember, she had that period of time where she went on that sex sabbatical. She did. That's right about when she got that mole removed. You remember her dermatologist? He was such a nice guy. Tall guy, tall guy, tall and had an accent. Yeah. But I could never figure out where he was from. Yeah. He made a very good dip. And you're like, what? You're like, where's the sweater from? Where's the sweater? Jenna and I just completely improvised this random conversation. But you guys know you've been in this moment. Yeah, that was Robert Dunder. And so Michael throws him out. Wait, can we also, sorry, this is hopping around. Can we also talk about how Michael introduces Robert to everyone? Please. He says, who is this worthless bag of bones? That's his introduction
首先记得，她有一段时间去进行了性休假。她确实去了。没错，就在她切除那个痣的时候。你记得她的皮肤科医生吗？他是个很好的人。高个子，高个子，高个子，还有口音。是的。但我从来没弄清楚他是哪里人。是的。他做了一种很好的蘸酱。你就像，什么？你就像，毛衣是从哪里来的？毛衣在哪里？珍娜和我完全即兴创作了这段随机对话。但你们知道你们经历过这一刻。是的，那是罗伯特·邓德。所以迈克尔把他赶了出去。等等，我们也可以，抱歉，这跳来跳去。我们也可以谈谈迈克尔是如何向每个人介绍罗伯特的吗？拜托。他说，这个毫无价值的骨头袋是谁？那是他的介绍
to the founder of the company. Well, we also had a fan question query from Aaron Kearney, who says, Robert Dunder mentions Robert Mifflin's wife and her husband, Jerry Truppiano, a South Jersey guy who was tall. My question is, was this a reference to Jerry Truppiano, the long time Red Sox broadcaster? I thought it might be because so many of the cast members and writers were Boston area folks. Well, I believe it to be true because Mike Scherr, who wrote this episode, is a huge baseball fan. Yeah. And I 100% think that's true. I think that's a good catch. Yeah. Good catch. Yeah, he's snuck in a baseball player in there. Well, as everyone is leaving the conference room, Ryan tells Michael, this day was a wash. Michael needs to embrace the new technology
给公司创始人。好吧，我们还有一个来自亚伦·卡尼的粉丝问题查询，他说，罗伯特·邓德提到了罗伯特·米夫林的妻子和她的丈夫，杰里·特鲁皮亚诺，一个来自南泽西的高个子男人。我的问题是，这是指长期担任红袜队播音员的杰里·特鲁皮亚诺吗？我以为可能是，因为很多演员和编剧都是波士顿地区的人。好吧，我相信这是真的，因为写这一集的迈克·舒尔是一个巨大的棒球迷。是的。我100%认为那是真的。我认为这是一个很好的捕捉。是的。很好的捕捉。是的，他把一个棒球运动员塞进去了。好吧，当每个人都离开会议室时，瑞安告诉迈克尔，这一天白费了。迈克尔需要拥抱新技术
as the way of the future. He really needs to get behind this new way of doing things. And Michael's like, no, you know what? I'm going to prove you wrong. That the old way is the best way. I'm going to prove you wrong. We don't know what that's going to be. But Michael says that. And Jenna, there is a deleted scene. I have to tell you, there's another department that's very stressed out about this because Ryan has a moment with the accountants where he shows them the new program they're going to use online for all of the accounting of Dunder Mifflin. And it's basically going to make them obsolete. Wow. So people are freaking out about this, this new technology that Dunder Mifflin is going to be using. Well, we're going to get more of Michael's reaction
作为未来的方式。他真的需要支持这种新的做事方式。迈克尔就像，不，你知道吗？我要证明你是错的。旧的方式是最好的方式。我要证明你是错的。我们不知道那会是什么。但迈克尔说了。珍娜，有一个被删减的场景。我必须告诉你，还有另一个部门对此感到非常紧张，因为瑞安和会计师们有一个时刻，他向他们展示了他们将在网上使用的用于邓德·米夫林所有会计工作的新程序。这基本上会让他们过时。哇。所以人们对邓德·米夫林将要使用的这种新技术感到恐慌。好吧，我们将得到更多迈克尔的反应
to all of this in the next episode. We end this episode, though, with Angela and Dwight's dinner date. Yes. Well, lady, I have some location trivia. I know you love a good location story. I do, and I will tell you Ivy Burke will be very excited to hear what you have to say because Ivy would like to know where you filmed the Dwight and Angela dinner. We filmed it in the most beautiful neighborhood. It's called the Malibu Lake Mountain Club. It's a private community, so much so that there are no signs off the freeway for it. Wow. Yeah, it's like they don't want to be found. It's really, really beautiful. This neighborhood was created in 1924. It was just like a valley and they made a lake, a manmade lake, and the members really wanted
对这一切在下一集中。不过，我们以安吉拉和德怀特的晚餐约会结束这一集。是的。好吧，女士，我有一些地点花絮。我知道你喜欢好的地点故事。我喜欢，我会告诉艾薇·伯克，她会很高兴听到你要说的话，因为艾薇想知道你们在哪里拍摄了德怀特和安吉拉的晚餐。我们在最美丽的社区拍摄的。它叫马里布湖山俱乐部。这是一个私人社区，以至于高速公路上没有路标。哇。是的，就像他们不想被找到一样。它真的，真的非常美丽。这个社区创建于1924年。它就像一个山谷，他们造了一个湖，一个人造湖，成员们真的想
to keep it a secret. So they removed the highway signs that gave directions to the lake, hoping to hide it from tourists. In 1936, they built a clubhouse with a ballroom and a large patio, and it had a speakeasy poker room and a mural of the original members, and only members can use the lake and the swimming pool in the tennis court. So it's this little private community. Ronald Reagan was the honorary mayor, and technically, that's the first political office he ever held. Wow. Now, let me ask you a question. Did you film at this location because this lake is going to feature prominently in the next episode? Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. Okay, so we had this location for one day. Dwight and Angela filmed their dinner date
保密。所以他们移除了指引湖方向的高速公路标志，希望把它从游客中隐藏起来。1936年，他们建造了一个带舞厅和大露台的会所，里面有一个地下酒吧扑克室和一幅原始成员的壁画，只有成员可以使用湖泊、游泳池和网球场。所以这是一个小小的私人社区。罗纳德·里根是荣誉市长，从技术上讲，那是他担任的第一个政治职位。哇。现在，让我问你一个问题。你们在这个地点拍摄是因为这个湖将在下一集中占据重要地位吗？叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。好吧，所以我们有一天的时间在这个地点。德怀特和安吉拉拍摄了他们的晚餐约会
in the lodge at Malibu Lake, their restaurant, and then we will see what happens to Michael and Dwight with the lake in the next episode. But that was all the same day. We filmed our scene at night, so Jenna, I had a late call time. Oh, there was this huge moon, and after we did the scene, I walked out on this floating dock and just watched the moon for a minute, and it was just like, you know, one of those magical nights on set where you're like, this feels so cool, because it's really a beautiful little area. And Steve Carell has made their official website ready for this. It says, just a few of the famous faces that have shot here. Charlie Chaplin, W.C. Fields, Diane Lane, Lloyd Bridges, Lucille Ball, Steve Carell, Betty Davis, Henry Fonda,
在马里布湖的旅馆，他们的餐厅，然后我们将在下一集中看到迈克尔和德怀特在湖边发生了什么。但那都是同一天。我们在晚上拍摄了我们的场景，所以珍娜，我有一个很晚的通告时间。哦，有一轮巨大的月亮，在我们拍完场景后，我走到这个浮动码头上，看了一会儿月亮，这就像，你知道，片场那些神奇的夜晚之一，你会觉得，这感觉太酷了，因为它真的是一个美丽的小区域。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔已经为他们的官方网站准备好了这个。上面写着，在这里拍摄过的一些名人面孔。查理·卓别林、W.C.菲尔兹、黛安·琳恩、劳埃德·布里奇斯、露西尔·鲍尔、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、贝蒂·戴维斯、亨利·方达，
it goes on and on, but Steve Carell made the list. I love that. I know, right? Really fun. But this scene between Rain and I, I just loved doing it. We took the scene apart because Dwight is hoping that it's one thing. Angela's trying for it to be a reconciliation. And then she just can't do it. Yeah. And they wanted me to be able to show that emotion in my face that I was trying. And then I just couldn't get past it. I couldn't get past it. And it's got a couplet of dialogue that I love. It's when Angela says, I heard a joke today. And Dwight says, Oh, that's funny. And Angela says, Yes, it was. Yeah. Well, this scene is just beautiful. It's beautiful for all the reasons you said it's funny,
它还在继续，但史蒂夫·卡瑞尔上了名单。我喜欢那个。我知道，对吧？真的很有趣。但瑞安和我之间的这一幕，我只是喜欢拍摄它。我们拆解了这一幕，因为德怀特希望这是一回事。安吉拉试图让它成为一次和解。然后她就是做不到。是的。他们希望我能够在我脸上表现出那种情感，我正在尝试。然后我就是无法克服它。我无法克服它。它有一对我很喜欢的对话。那是安吉拉说，我今天听了一个笑话。德怀特说，哦，那很有趣。安吉拉说，是的，确实。是的。好吧，这一幕很美。它很美，因为你说的所有原因，它很有趣，
but then it breaks your heart because your performance, Angela, we really see your character's heart breaking in this moment. And it's just real. Like you aren't playing it for comedy. It's just real. And these are the moments of the office that I'm so proud of as a television comedy that we took these moments to get really real. Thanks, lady. Thanks. I really enjoyed the storyline. I loved Dwight and Angela being together. And I loved when they were at odds. It was equally fun to play. Yeah, it's such a good dynamic. Well, you know, Jenna, one of the things that got me so tickled was that during this time, the Dwight-Angela relationship was compared by a TV journalist to Hot Lips Hulahan and Frank from MASH. And that was a show I grew up watching with
但随后它又让你心碎，因为安吉拉，我们真的看到了你的角色在这一刻心碎了。而且这非常真实。就像你不是在演喜剧一样。这很真实。这些就是《办公室》中让我作为一部电视喜剧感到非常自豪的时刻，我们抓住了这些时刻，让它变得非常真实。谢谢你，女士。谢谢。我真的很喜欢这个故事情节。我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉在一起，也喜欢他们针锋相对的时候。演起来同样有趣。是的，这种动态关系太棒了。你知道吗，珍娜，有一件事让我特别高兴，那就是在那段时间里，一位电视记者将德怀特和安吉拉的关系比作《陆军野战医院》中的“热唇”霍利汉和弗兰克。那是我从小和我爸爸一起看的节目。我对此感到非常高兴。哦，那太完美了。这就是《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第一部分。是的。我想感谢乔亚·巴尔福为我们提供数字媒体的内部信息。你可以访问她的网站 JoyaBalfour.com，看看他们在 NBC.com 上做的一些有趣的事情。好吧，当我们继续这个故事情节时，我们将会有一些可爱的礼品篮和一个巨大的特技表演，特别是针对我们的节目。我印象非常深刻。我迫不及待想谈谈它了。好了，祝大家这周过得愉快。我们下次见。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。
my dad. And I just was so tickled by that. Oh, that's perfect. And that was Dunder Mifflin Infinity part one. Yes. And I would like to say thank you to Joya Balfour for giving us the digital media inside info. And you can check out her website at JoyaBalfour.com for some fun stuff that they were doing at NBC.com. Well, when we pick up this storyline, we're going to have some lovely gift baskets and a huge stunt, especially for our show. I was so impressed. I can't wait to talk about it. All right, you guys have a great week. We'll see you next time. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer.
我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 StitcherPremium 一个月，请使用代码 Office。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.